okay so that's sort of the story from
the top of the hierarchy if we can go
now to people who would be in a follower
role or what's the advice in that role
you feel a little tamp down but there's
an opportunity with someone new you're
unhappy but what's your advice and
you're going for organizational
effectiveness right okay so the general
advice to people in quote-unquote low
power positions about how to communicate
what their experience is and or to
promote some sort of change that they
believe would help do the job better the
general advice is you need to actually
come together as a group so that you
need a friend you need three or four
other people individually the person who
you go to talk to let's say you had
courage you were one person with courage
the person in the leadership role
doesn't know how to evaluate that
information it's just coming from one
person it could be one person's
perspective and and genuinely the person
doesn't know how to wait if there are
twelve people in the in the ensure they
don't know how to wait the one person
coming they could collect some data and
many organizations do that is they use
somebody coming or something written
anonymously to collect data about how
widespread that thought or feeling is so
as to decide whether action needs to be
taken on it to improve the organization
effectiveness but the other thing you
can do is you can do that organization
in the low power position it makes a big
difference to someone in a position of
authority if six people come and say hey
we've been thinking about this and we
want to tell you what we think about the
way in which things are done now we're
proposing it much more effective in
terms of the person at the top of the
hierarchy hearing listening to the
thoughts and feelings it's so generally
my advice to people at the bottom is you
have to sort of see whether you're the
only one who's got this thought or
feeling and if there are more people you
have to try to get all the people to to
come together to express it and my
advice to a person in a leadership role
is to not think of this as an assault
but
as a way of collecting data for you if
I'm in the authority role and a group
comes to me and says here's what we
think my question is are there
variations in that so I'm interested in
the what they're mainly trying to tell
me and whether there are any differences
in there whether they've been whether
there's some effect for the group that's
causing him to all speak with one voice
when in fact they have different
thoughts and feelings about it which
would help me understand the situation
better so I'm going to put you in a
harder situation and this would be in a
low-power group let's say it's all of
the nursing and technical staff that are
in the o.r and there are just issues
with the way the surgeons and
anesthesiologists are running the o.r
that make it really difficult to be
effective that is save all patients no
infections complications etc and they do
all feel like but the last history when
they've brought this up it's been sort
of yeah got that nothing we can do move
on you know there they've been sort of
dismissed when they've brought this how
does a person in that role or a group in
that role really make a decision about
whether I should just keep trying on
this or what advice can we give how do
people who are in a followership role
actually lean in that way so there's a
there's an interesting book which as you
know is about economics but it speaks to
essentially this question and the title
of the book is very instructive in some
ways the title of the book is exit voice
and loyalty and it essentially says that
in order to create learning systems that
people who are participating in that
system employees have basically three
options when something is not going
right and these options are framed in
terms of actually how to make the
organization more effective one of them
is to leave because by leaving you are
taking your skill and your ability and
you're saying this is not a place that I
want to contribute my skill to because
it's not it's hurting patients or it's
not helping them as much as they get
this is an extreme act
we all know examples where we're glad
people did that because it it woke up an
organization to a negative thought and
feeling and caused it to make some
changes it was not terribly easy we we
don't hear from these people very often
afterwards because it's tremendously
costly for the individual who does it
the second thing was voice which is that
the the notion that you have to find
some way to express what it is that
you're struggling with and think are
critiquing about the organization and
this is as your as you your question
suggests it's very difficult to do and
sometimes it has to its translated into
exit because of the frustration that
voice is not being heard now the guy
wrote the book Albert Hirschman made the
case that we and organizations should
prefer to have people express their
critique you know the saying what they
think and feel because it contains
information for the organization to
adjust to its to its task etc that we
should do whatever we can to keep people
from leaving because when they leave
they take with them their information
which might help make the organization
better and my interpretation is this is
what he meant by loyalty that is we need
to define loyalty as giving voice to
what we're thinking and feeling about
the task that's in front of us not
defined loyalty as getting with the
program and so I think my advice is the
low power people would be you might have
to leave or you might have to say to
your supervisor I don't want to be in
that o/r anymore yep and then put your
putting pressure on the organization to
say why not or reassign you right and
then pretty soon that creates some
information in the system about why are
people leaving this person's o-r what's
going on in that or and then we turn our
attention to but you've just cast
loyalty as a very positive thing that
allows voice also so I just wondered if
you could run over that again because I
think it's a very interesting should we
be training our followers to be loyal
and what does that really mean
so it's a great question and and I would
come at it in two ways what I said
before was we need to do we need to
convey that loyalty includes one's
critique of the of the organization
loyalty traditionally I mean in blind
loyalty means it doesn't matter what you
are thinking and feeling
you do what you are told to do by the
organization and I was recasting that
what we need to do in organisations
actually I think this is what Hirshman
was saying is we need to recast loyalty
as not blindly saying only positive
thoughts about the organization but
rather loyalty is saying what you
actually think and feel about what we're
doing it keeps you from going off the
cliff because you can depend on people
saying I think there's a cliff out there
and you can't see it because you're
sitting in a bottom seat and I'm sitting
in a top seat and I can see where that
where the cliff is and you can and I
need to tell you that it's there so
that's one thing the other piece about
way of thinking about loyalty is it's
loyalty to a task and a mission rather
than to an individual and the question
there always is what is the primary task
of this organization and does this
contribute to it I may not always know
whether it does or not but if I'm
thinking that something you've asked me
to do does not contribute to the central
task of this organization
then I'm obliged to say it in my
definition of effectiveness I may have
information from others who say their
perspective that may change the way I
think about it but my job take a
hospital you know doc prescribed a
certain number of milligrams of a drug
and the nurse says I think his men he's
multiplied this by a factor of 10 not
necessarily on purpose but hopefully not
wasn't it
what's my loyalty yeah to follow the
orders or to say doc could you check the
book on this because my reading what I
was trained is that this is a lot more
that to which the doc might say oh of
right it's 25 not 250 or the doc might
say just do what I tell you to do in
which case there have been examples of
what the nurse is is well you'll have to
get somebody else to do that because I
don't believe I believe this is
dangerous to the patient and my job here
is to take care of patients I think
that's what our task is as a hospital
now this is very hard to do so they go
back to your question about individual
courage I think the nurse is more likely
to do that if the training of nurses
if the nursing supervisor has said the
definition of loyalty is saying what you
think and feel you will not be punished
for it you will be promoted for it
easier for anybody to do that then if
none of that's been said or if the nurse
manager says you do whatever the doc
tells you I don't care whether it's
whether it's to give it ten times the
dosage we're not going to get in the
position of taking on the docs here
that's not our job
you